>>> Ladies and gentlemen, would you please
welcome Patrick Mork.
[ Applause ]
>>Patrick Mork: Thank you.
It's great to see everybody today.
Welcome to the marketing session of apps marketing
101 for developers for Google Play.
Delighted to see everybody here.
It's been a pretty amazing day, at least to
say it's been a surprise, it's been full of
surprises even for some of us on the marketing
team.
It's been really exciting.
20 billion app downloads, of course, on Google
Play.
One and a half billion downloads every single
month.
And, of course, the source of a lot of those
revenues, as you've seen from some of the
previous sessions, in application billing,
of course, being on a tear.
We're going to talk to you about marketing
today, spend a couple of minutes on how we
market the store and your apps to consumers,
which I think could be of interest to a number
of you, and then talk about app marketing
in itself, what is app marketing all about,
how should we do it?
What kind of frameworks can we share with
you and what kind of tools can we share with
you?
Let's think about marketing for a second.
And probably some of you out there in the
audience have heard of the famous four Ps.
Who's heard of the four Ps?
Okay.
A couple people.
Well, let's talk first of all what the four
Ps are not.
Please, please, please, please download my
application.
Please, please, please buy my app.
Yes, you can do marketing that way, of course,
it's not the most effective.
But we're going to talk about all the tricks
in the books that have to do with marketing,
including the real four Ps which we'll get
to in a minute.
One of the things I want to share is a little
bit our friendly neighborhood checklist for
what it is to do marketing when we're talking
about apps.
So if your eyes do kind of start glazing over
at this point, it is 4:00 in the afternoon.
It's been a very exciting day.
Don't worry.
The presentation is going to be available
offline.
And we'll have versions for you to download,
especially of this particular slide.
What we're going to talk about is basically
our apps, our business models, how to promote
applications, and how to distribute applications.
And what we've done, actually, for all you
developers in the house to make this even
easier is we've kind of color-coded everything.
So, basically, if you're a new developer or
you're a developer who don't potentially have
a lot of experience developing or marketing
applications, then there's a lot of this is
going to be new to you, especially the stuff
in blue, which is the basic stuff on marketing
that you should be looking at.
If you're already a little bit more advanced
or an intermediate developer with some basic
marketing experience, you're going to want
to look at all the things that are highlighted
in green.
And, of course, for those of you who have
been really successful, or some of the larger
developers who are making some money on Android,
which is always great news to hear, then a
lot of the color coded stuff in red is advanced.
But before we go into the actual nuts and
bolts, let's play a little video which gives
you a good idea of how we actually market
apps to consumers.
This is gears and premiers exclusively at
Google Play.
[ Video.
]
>>> Suppose you buy an app on your computer
to send to your smartphone.
You might need a cable to transfer it from
one to the other.
And if you want it on your tablet, you need
to transfer it again.
Suppose you used Google Play.
You can buy an app on your computer and send
it to any of your Android devices instantly,
with no cables.
Because Google Play makes your apps available
anywhere, so you can enjoy them everywhere.
Google Play, your entertainment all simply
here.
[ Video concludes.
]
>>Patrick Mork: So this is kind of a little
bit just an example of how we're actually
getting out there and really starting to market
applications on your behalf and going out
and talking to consumers.
I think it's also worth sharing a little bit
what are the other kinds of things that we're
doing to market Google Play.
In particular, one of the things that's worth
sharing with all of you in the room and all
of the people in our international audience
who are live streaming this today, is just
how much effort is going into marketing the
store.
In the first six weeks of launch alone, we
did over 5 billion impressions to consumers
all over the world.
Not to mention a lot of the other advertising
that you may have seen, for example, seeing
Google Play available on the nav bar across
all our Google properties.
Or a lot of the emails in CRM that we've been
doing or a lot of the work that we've been
doing with partners.
The advertising effort on behalf of the team
at Google Play and the marketing team has
been nothing less than spectacular over the
past couple of months and is only going to
grow and accelerate over time.
More importantly, though -- and this is really
kind of, like, a big callout to all of you
in the room and to awesome of the developers
who have supported us, as Hugo said in his
keynote -- is there's been a lot of love from
the developer community, there's been a lot
of support from all our content partners,
whether that's game developers, app developers,
books publishers, music labels, and movie
studios.
Really, kind of the feedback that we've gotten
from the community, from all our partners,
has been tremendous.
And has really also helped accelerate the
awareness of consumers of what Google Play
is and as a destination to get all the things
content for their devices.
So this has been amazing, and we really thank
you for that.
But let's get to the nitty-gritty.
Let's get to the stuff that we're really interested
in and excited about.
And that is, how do we actually market apps?
Well, one of the ways that we look at things
at Google, and we encourage our partners to
do the same, is really this very simple matrix
that our CMO, Lorraine Twohill, has come up
with, which really guides the essence and
philosophy of marketing at Google.
And that is really understanding users, building
magical experiences -- which in this case
is you guys building magical applications
-- and then really connecting the two.
So let's take a really kind of bizarre but
fun and specific example of how that works
in reality when we talk about apps.
Let's say that you're a carpenter.
Or you're doing DIY in your house.
And you're fixing chairs and you're hanging
frames up on your wall and you're maybe adjusting
beams, you know, in your house and you're
doing all sorts of work in your house.
Well, how cool would it be if when you're
putting that frame up on the wall, the one
that you kind of like have to ask your wife
to sit 50 meters behind you to tell if you
it's crooked or straight, how cool would it
be if you had a little application that could
do that for you?
Like Ben Zibble's bubble app.
I could fire up my bubble app and place my
phone on top of that frame and see if the
frame is perfectly aligned or not.
Saves me a lot of time.
Makes my life easier, and to some extent as
well, it's kind of a magical experience.
The point is that applications are either
enhancing our lives or making our lives more
productive, or they're entertaining us.
And they do it in such a way that really has
a magical quality and component to it.
And our role as marketers and your role as
marketers is, how do we connect those two.
How do we connect the magic of the apps that
we build with, essentially, an entertaining
experience for a consumer or a productive
experience for consumers?
But, really, before we actually get into the
nuts and bolts of the four Ps themselves,
let's talk about research for a minute.
Because when you talk about users, it really
starts with research.
Before you even write that first line of code,
you really have to understand who your consumers
are, what they're doing, how they download
apps, where they download apps, and how they
consume and use those applications.
And, really, it's a lot simpler than would
you think.
People always think, oh, research.
They think about IDC or they think about Nielsen
or they think about tens of thousand of dollars
spent on research.
It's really not that complex or that expensive.
The way we break it down, for example, is
we look at quantitative versus qualitative
research.
At its very basic level, your quantitative
research is basically when you go out and
you do extensive questionnaires and you survey
thousands of different consumers or hundreds
of different consumers.
And you're asking the basic questions that
you're trying to get answered.
How often does this consumer download applications?
What kind of handsets are they using?
How much per month are they spending downloading
applications?
How long are they spending in an application
session?
You're really trying to understand kind of
the macro, broad picture of consumer demographics
and habits and consumption to guide the development
philosophy for your application.
Then, of course, as you start building your
application, you get near that famous milestone,
that first milestone of having a beta or an
alpha, then, really, it's about qualitative
research.
And qualitative research can take a lot of
different forms, like focus groups, for example.
Or screen focus groups, or just sitting down
with a bunch of people that you may or may
not know that well around pizza and beers
and trying to understand what they think of
your app.
And this is really the in-depth part of the
market research, which is where you're really
trying to understand how's the consumer using
my app?
How quickly does my app load?
What kind of features do they like?
How easy is the UI to navigate?
And what kind of features could enhance the
application?
Or better yet, what features should I remove
because the consumers simply don't either
get the features or they don't really use
the features?
The best news about research and its ability
to guide our development philosophy, as I
said earlier, is that it's neither that expensive
or that time-consuming.
You can start right now and you can do research
online.
You can go, for example, to google.com/insights,
put together three simple questions, survey
1500 consumers and get answers in three to
four days at less than $1,000.
On the quantitative side.
And your focus groups -- again, this is something
you just need to know enough people that you
can get together groups of people and spend
an afternoon brainstorming and getting feedback.
It's really not that hard and there's a lot
of tools available to do that.
And now introducing the real four Ps.
So how did the real four Ps influence our
marketing and our thinking around app marketing?
Well, of course, when we talk about the real
four Ps, we're talking about product, which
is our app.
We're talking about price, which is our business
model.
We're talking about distribution, which ends
up being how many devices are we covering?
What operating systems are we developing on?
And what channels within those operating systems
are we distributing on?
And lastly, we're talking about promotions,
which can be anything from the type of assets
that we build, the thumbnails, the screen
shots, the assets, the videos, our banners,
search ads, all the kind of tools that we
would use to promote our applications.
So talking about product, and I love this
analogy, and it's actually even better to
use this analogy at 4:00 in the afternoon,
because by that point, I know most of you
people have eaten, so you're not starving,
and you won't just run out of the room when
you see all this stuff that's on the slide.
But truth be told, the way I look at it is
it's about snacking versus feasting.
Right?
So around 4:00 or 5:00 in the afternoon, like
right now, you might have a little hunger.
You might want a little something to snack
on.
So you grab, you know, a Snickers bar or you'll
grab a bag of chips.
And you open that bag of chips, and you will
push your hand into the bag, and you will
take out one or two chips.
But you're not going to put your hand in and
take all the chips out of the bag and stuff
them in your face.
Well, some people might, but you probably
won't.
It's really something that you do just to
kill the hunger at that particular point in
time, versus, of course, feasting, which is
what's going to happen around 11:00 or midnight
tonight after you've been hearing Paul Oakenfold
and you're starving and you need about five
courses.
Totally different experience.
Why am I using this example?
Mobile app usage and mobile app consumption
is all about snacking.
It's not about feasting.
If you look at the research, the research
that we see and the research that's publicly
available will tell you that on average, consumers
are spending probably around an hour and a
half per day using apps.
So what does that tell us?
Well, that tells us that if they're spending
about an hour and a half per day using apps,
and they've got maybe 30 apps on their phone,
of which they use ten frequently, well, they're
probably going to use your app no more than
nine or ten minutes a day.
Sounds obvious.
But what's the implication for product development?
There's a couple of implications.
The first implication is that if I'm -- as
a consumer, I'm using my favorite app, and
I'm using it for five minutes a day, if I
get a notification from you that says that
I need to update my application, activate
my Wi-Fi, and download two gigabytes of files
-- well, maybe with smart apps, now that's
going to be easier.
But that still kind of goes against the philosophy
of snacking.
Why am I going to spend five minutes downloading
a file when I'm using the app maybe nine minutes
every single day?
It has implications in terms of the load speed;
right?
If I'm getting on a bus and I've got two stops
and I want to check my sports scores or I
want to see what the weather's like in London
-- we know what the weather's like in London
-- but if I want to see what the weather is
like in London, I don't want the application
to take 20 to 30 seconds to load.
I want to dip my hand into the experience,
dip it out, get my information, thank you
very much, and I'm done.
And it has lots of other implications as well.
Right?
It has implications in terms of how easy is
the application to use.
Let's say that I am on that bus in London
and I've got about 15 minutes' commute.
Well, am I going to spend five minutes of
those 15 minutes actually reading through
all, like, you know, the options that are
available in the app and trying to read and
understand how the app works?
Probably not.
I really want to get into the experience quickly,
which means I need an intuitive UI, I need
very easy-to-use features, I need to be able
to dip in and dip out very quickly.
So understanding your users and understanding
that people snack has direct implications
for how you develop content.
So let's talk for a minute about great applications.
And there are thousands of great applications.
And, of course, we can't possibly cite them
all.
But this is an old-school example that I like
to use.
eBuddy is a Dutch developer that's been around
since 2005, 2006, started originally developing
J2ME apps.
I remember that fondly, because I started
my career in games trying to sell J2ME games
to carriers five years ago.
And hence the first slide about please, please,
please.
You probably get the rest of the picture.
Needless to say, obviously, you know, these
guys have been around a very long time.
And they do a lot of things really, really
well.
So what we did was we put together a handy
little checklist together for these guys for
what we think they do well.
A couple of things.
First of all, the product really solves a
clear and present need.
As I mentioned earlier, at the beginning of
my speech, you're either entertaining or you're
addressing a specific issue or making the
person's life easier.
eBuddy does that basically by aggregating
five or six different IMs into one easy to
use client where you can be logged into all
your instant messengers and be chatting with
your friends anywhere in the world no matter
what instant messenger they're using.
They saw the need.
They had excellent device coverage.
One of the things that amazes me about developers
is that sometimes we'll see these great apps,
and they'll be, like, 500 megabytes in size
and have a black list of 1200 devices.
Well, one of the ways that you basically get
noticed in the apps market is through virality.
And virality means reach.
And reach means device coverage.
These guys have a very simple app that works
very quickly, it's easy to use, it loads quickly,
the UI is super intuitive and they're available
across lots of different devices.
As a matter of fact, they're available on
nearly every device from Android 1.5 and up.
Now, I'm not telling you guys need to go back
and develop on 1.5.
But what I'm saying is, you need to be available
on as many devices as are relevant to maximize
your virality.
Of course, the other thing that's important
with this application which goes without saying
and also helps virality is parity of features
across operating systems.
If I have a great application that I get on
Android and it's got these cool features and
I tell my friend about it and he's got an
iPhone, he goes out and downloads it and it
doesn't have the same features, that's kind
of a crummy experience for him.
Right?
Likewise, if the opposite happens that somebody
gets a great application on iOS and then tells
their friend and their friend downloads the
Android version and it's a port, that's not
a really cool thing to do, either.
And, as a matter of fact, when you talk about
placement and getting featured in the Google
Play Store, that is a sure way not to get
featured in the Play Store.
Right?
We want to make sure that Android consumers
have the best possible experience, and, if
possible, a better experience than on other
platforms.
And lastly, continuously upgrading the application,
making sure that you're constantly fixing
bugs, constantly removing features that are
out of date, constantly improving on new features,
and making sure that the quality of your application
isn't just good when you launch, but it's
continuously and consistently good across
all your revisions.
And if you look at eBuddy, they have a 4.3
rating across 155,000 reviews.
And they have done 10 to 50 million downloads
on Google Play, which is actually a lot more
than some of the better-known apps than we
know here in the Valley.
So a lot of different things to (indiscernible)
over on our checklist.
So you've heard a lot with productive from
me, but I'd like to turn it over to a video
from one of our top developers to talk about
their experience on product.
[ Video.
]
>>> My name is Perry Tam, I'm CEO and cofounder
of Storm8.
>>> And I'm Vatsal Bhardwaj, product manager
for growth initiatives here at Storm8.
>>> At Storm8, we make social games for mobile.
In the past three years, we have created 30
titles, and they have been downloaded more
than 300 million times on more than 100 million
devices.
>>> When we look at marketing and marketing
strategy at Storm8, it actually starts with
the product concept.
So when we are thinking about what game we
are going to build next, that's when marketing
starts.
So we do a lot of rigorous market research,
surveying of our users to understand what
kind of games, what kind of features, game
mechanics will deliver the most fun.
>>> So to deliver high-quality product for
our users, there are really three things which
go with that.
The first is a very strong focus on the target
consumers.
The second piece is a solid product and product
management process.
And then the third piece is add Analytics
and data capabilities.
We pay a lot of attention to who are our target
users, where are they located, what kind of
Android devices they are using.
>>> There was a time that we did, like, 40%
of pricing to test out what would that drive
the effect of, you know, our users' behavior.
We also did maybe drop the price to 99 cents
for a limited time period.
And from those tests, we collect a lot of
data as to whether they convert more free
users to paying users or actually could be
detrimental to us down the road.
>>> We pay a lot of attention to packaging
of our games.
So it includes things like the screen shots,
the app icon, the description.
And we want to make sure that it's well optimized
so that users who love that game can easily
discover it.
We have a very strong data and analytics team.
And throughout the process, we make sure we
do regress analysis and measurement to, again,
create the game that's going to be most fun
for our users.
[ Video concludes.
]
>>Patrick Mork: Great.
So there you have a little bit from Storm8.
But as I hope you noticed, research, rigorous
development process, really iterating and
really understanding the data, right, critical
to getting the product right.
But, of course, although we like to make great
apps and games, you know, if we can't pay
the water bill at the end of the month, it
all becomes a little bit hairy; right?
So no conversation would be complete, you
know, without talking about business models.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time here,
because, of course, many of you just sat through
a session on monetization with Kenneth Lui
and his colleagues.
I think they did an excellent job of describing
the various models out there.
What I will try and do is add a little bit
my two cents and experience based on how to
look at each one of these individual models
and some of the unique variables that affect
each.
So, you know, you've heard about freemium,
you've heard about the march of freemium and
how well that's doing.
As Chris mentioned, it's over 50% of our revenue
now which is exciting.
And we've seen a huge takeoff in freemium
over the last months.
That's not to say that it's the right model
for you.
That's not to say that it's going to make
you super competitive against the other apps
on your system.
As we see, freemium works better in some categories
versus others.
We really have to understand what the right
price points are when it comes to freemium.
What's going to be the way to engage with
consumers?
How often do we provide notifications to consumers?
What kind of notifications do we provide and
at what price points?
So it's really about testing, testing, re-understanding,
changing the pricing, looking at price elasticity,
and really measuring and analyzing what works.
More importantly, I think one of the questions
I want to address directly is talked about
paid applications.
Because many of your applications out there
will still be paid apps.
And as mentioned earlier, freemium might not
work for you.
So let's spend a minute talking about paid
applications.
And I really wanted to talk about two things
when it has to do with paid apps.
Because even though we're in the world of
smartphones and Java is long gone from now,
well, there's still a lot of things that don't
change.
There's still a lot of constants that remain
the same.
One of those is the challenge around pricing.
So the myth around the 99-cent price point
or the 99-cent dilemma as I call it, here's
the dilemma: The dilemma is that if you look
at a curve and you look at the number of applications
available on the Android platform or on iOS
for that matter, you'll see the left side
of the curve where the majority of the apps
lie are where most of those apps are at 99
cents.
And here's the problem with that.
Well, the problem is that if you price your
app at 99 cents from the get-go, how do you
discount?
If you want to put your app on sale, where
do you go from 99 cents?
You can't.
It's a lot harder.
And one of the rules of marketing, you'll
hear several of those today, is very simple,
and it's this: It's always a lot easier to
take your price down than to raise your price.
In any product, in any category, in any supermarket,
in any industry, it's always the same case.
So our recommendation there is, if you are
going to have paid apps, always start at a
slightly higher price point, because it gives
you flexibility to discount and make offers
on your application.
The other reason why we believe pricing at
99 cents is a risk is because, ultimately,
most of us, when we go to make a purchase,
let's say we're buying a pair of sneakers
or buying a pair of jeans or we're buying,
I don't know, a plane ticket, having a lower
price tells us a certain thing about the product
that we're buying.
And in many cases, low price equals cheap.
So the question to you, then, is, is that
the kind of message that you want to pass
to your consumer?
The person that's seeing your app for the
first time?
That maybe sees your app side by side with
five other competitors, and you're the cheapest
app?
That sometimes works for consumers who are
really price-sensitive.
But for other consumers, they'll look at that
and say, "This app basically does the same,
so it's probably not as good."
And that does happen.
More likely what we like to did is we like
to encourage you guys to really think about
the price life cycle of your application.
What we've done is build kind of a theoretical
model on what that looks like.
In this particular case, an app developer
launches an app or game at 2.99 and they get
a certain number of installs.
The first month, it's 50,000.
The second month, it's another 40,000.
The third month, it starts to drop.
And at that point, because they priced at
2.99, they're able to able to drop the price.
So they drop the price to 1.99, and they get
a whole bunch of new users who go, "Oh, yes,
great.
An offer.
I'm going to get this app now."
And they share with their friends, and they
say, "You know, I was a cheap bastard before.
I didn't want to buy it at $3.
But now it's at 2.
I'm in."
So they buy the app.
And the friends start piling in and you get
a little bit of virality because they're getting
a great deal.
What do you do?
You raise the price.
Once you start getting that volume build and
that momentum, you raise the price.
A lot of consumers who may have heard about
how great your app was, they don't necessarily
realize the price is no longer discounted,
so they still buy it.
And you can basically get the difference of
what you were charging before versus after.
And you can do that in cycles over time, until
you get to the end of the life cycle, or maybe
12 months or eight months out or whatever
your product plan is, you decide you're going
to phase out that app and launch a completely
new one.
What do you do, since you priced at 2.99,
you're going to drop the price to 99 cents,
that's a great bargain.
You can do that because you're at the end
of your price cycle and you're going to introduce
another app anyway.
There what I'm saying is theoretical model
but encourage you to think of what is the
price life cycle of my app, how do I manage
it over a time and how do I give myself enough
flexibility with my price point that I can
move and pivot and change my price if I have
to?
Let's talk about ads.
So this chart was taken from a Kleiner Perkins
presentation by Mary Meeker.
Some of you guys may read Mary Meeker on occasion
when she publishes material on the Internet
specifically and about mobile Internet.
And the thing about ads is this: There's some
good news and there's some opportunistic news;
right?
The reality about ads is that ads today in
terms of ECPMs, which is the effective cost
per thousand or what you're getting paid for
your ads, is the ECPMs on mobile are significantly
lower than on desktop.
No surprise; right?
Desktop's been around ten years, has a different
user base.
They spend perhaps more time on desktop, so
the value of ECPM is higher.
Mobile is still a lot lower.
But the good news is, when you look at this
graph, you'll see that the yellow bar, the
bar on the left across all of these different
types of media, that's the amount of time
spent by consumers.
So what do we see here?
Well, we see that on average, consumers are
spending about 10% of their time on mobile,
which is huge.
That's massively encouraging for every single
one of us in this room and every single one
of us around the world who is developing great
content.
The challenge is, only 1% of the ad dollars
are flowing into mobile today.
But that means a massive opportunity.
Why?
Simple.
Dollars always follow eyeballs.
That's just the way advertising works.
There's always a lag.
Which means, essentially, if you have a great
product and you really understand how to monetize
through ads, it's a question of time before
that gap closes and before the ECPMs either
get close to or match what we see on desktops
and enable you guys to really maximize the
monetization of your apps through ads.
I think the last point I want to make -- well,
two more points on monetization before moving
on -- is, use hybrids.
We saw that earlier.
We talked -- we saw paymium.
We saw a combination of different business
models.
And this is really exciting stuff because
what we're seeing is more and more developers
are starting to do that and it's starting
to pay dividends.
And it also reduces your risk as a developer.
So if you have in-app payments, that's great.
Why not throw in app ads if it makes sense,
and you can potentially monetize from both
or you can see which works better than the
other.
Having a hybrid and a combination of different
business models gives you more flexibility
and maximizes your ability to monetize your
apps.
Last point on monetization.
We live in a global world.
Apps are being downloaded every single second,
all over the world, on all sorts of different
devices.
So what are the implications for you as app
developers?
Simple.
Different business models will work differently
in different countries.
So if you've got a great game in the United
States where you know that a lot of consumers,
may be 60% plus of consumers are on contract
and have higher-end smartphones, chances are
those consumers are more willing to pay for
your app, therefore, a paid app or in-app
payments might make more sense for you.
But if you're trying to distribute and monetize
your apps in India, where, potentially, 90
to 95% of consumers are on prepaid cards and
they're still in the process of rolling out
3G networks where data is expensive, then
perhaps that business model doesn't work as
well and you need to think of maybe I should
monetize through ads.
The reality there is, try and look at your
market globally and see how you can monetize
your app using different business models in
different regions.
Be creative.
So once we've built this great product and
we know how we're going to monetize it and
keep all the lights on at the end of the day,
well, then we start thinking about, aha, how
do I promote my app?
Where should I spend my money?
Where should I spend those hard-earned VC
dollars that are going to enable me to get
more users, yay, another rule of marketing,
rule number two numero uno, don't invest behind
a weak product.
It goes behind saying.
But you see people do this all the time, and
not just in our business, but in tons of businesses.
If you invest behind a weak product, you're
basically creating a negative consumer perception
of your product and of your brand, if that's
what you're trying to build.
You should go back to the drawing board and
rework your application until you're sure
that you have the best possible experience.
If you're not excited about your application
or you're not convinced you would pay, do
you think a consumer is because they're going
to see an ad that you're seeing on AdMob or
somewhere else?
Probably not.
Once you're really sure that you have a great
product, then there's a number of great frameworks
we can suggest to you that are going to help
you put together your marketing plan.
The first of these is STP.
Knowing your users.
It's all about segmenting, targeting, and
then positioning your app properly.
The second one is once I position my app properly,
I know who I'm going after, what's the message
I'm giving the consumer?
What is my one liner?
What are my points of difference?
Why should a consumer care?
Third, once I have all my messaging down and
I've properly positioned my app and I know
where I'm going, it's, well, how do I build
a structured marketing plan?
What needs to go into my marking plan?
What kind of activity should I do?
Lastly, what is my media strategy look like.
The good news is I'm going to go through each
one of these in detail and explain in detail
a little more clearly.
Let's look at our audience.
So let's say, for example, I'm a game developer
and I've seen this great case study from Kenneth
Lui at Google I/O, I've decided, you know
what, that's it, dude, I'm going for in-app
payments.
I'm going to do in-app payments with, like,
funky furry animals at different price points.
I'm going to get a ton of downloads to get
consumers to basically pay me a the lot of
money.
If you are going to do in-app payments on
games, then probably what you need to do is
really segment your target audience properly
and look at how you target those people.
Excuse me.
So if I'm using in-app payments for game,
there's two axis probably that I'm going to
look at.
I'm going to look at available time.
I need people to have available time to play
my games.
And then I'm probably going to look at disposable
income.
Because if a person is 13 years old and has
tons of available time but no income, I'm
not going to make much money from them.
I segment my audience this way.
I come up with all these different segments
that I have.
Upscale adults, techies, middle income families,
soccer moms, whatever it happens to be.
And when I look at my matrix, I think, okay,
the right target audience is probably these
guys.
Young adults 24-35 years old, no kids, right?
So they have disposable time and they have
income.
That's my target audience.
Then it's a question of, okay, how do I position
my app?
What's my one-liner to those people?
What am I going to tell those people to click
and install my application?
Which takes us to the next step.
How do I develop convincing messaging?
What's the one line that I'm going to tell
people about my sports application that is
going to get them so excited that they are
going to want to download it?
Is it that I have realtime instantaneous scores?
Is it the fact that I'm the only application
that has social engagement and built-in hangouts
into it?
Is it the fact that I have this application
that runs on all sorts of different platforms
and backs up my data on the web?
What's your one liner?
What's your positioning statement?
After that, what are the two or three key
points of difference that are going to go
into my product description?
So that when people land on my page, because
they have searched or clicked an ad, they
read these three or four great things about
the application.
Not the bug fixes, but the stuff that really
matters.
They think, this app is really cool because
it has Android beam and I can do all this
crazy stuff like play multiplayer games without
activating Bluetooth or Wi-Fi.
That's wicked cool.
I'm going to get that instead of that other
application.
And lastly, what's my call to action?
When you start doing Get Creative, we see
app developers do ad campaigns, online stuff,
banners, they advertise their little logo
with a little dragon and it doesn't tell me
anything about what I should do next.
Okay, so you've got me all excited about your
little furry animals and I can get these collectable
items, what do I do?
Where do I go?
Where can I find this app?
Clear calls to action.
On the right-hand side -- actually I thought
it would be fun to share this.
Kushagra, who is working with us right here
on the Google Play team and actually is the
one who really was responsible for a lot of
this material as well as the interviews, so
I owe him a huge debt of gratitude on that.
Kushagra put together an amazing promotion
at the end of last year around apps.
Some of you guys may have seen it.
In December, we hit 10 billion downloads.
We did a promotion called 10-10-10.
I really need a beer.
[ Laughter ]
>>Patrick Mork: Water just doesn't do it.
Anyway.
We put together this promotion called 10-10-10.
That was to celebrate 10 billion downloads
and that now seems like a long time ago, right?
20 billion now, great stuff.
We put together this promotion called 10-10-10.
We had three key things we want today communicate
to consumers.
10 days, 10-cent apps, 10 apps a day.
Really simple.
Yet, even though it was so simple, as you
can see going from top to bottom, we went
through several different versions of creative
material to get to the right creative.
You are not even seeing all of it because
it wouldn't fit on the slide.
We went through version after version after
version after version after version of getting
the creative right.
And the point here is whether it's your thumbnails
or your video or your text descriptions, you
iterate, iterate, iterate, iterate until you
get it right.
And you test and test and test and test until
you get it right.
Just like you do with your product.
Creative is an iterative process, but it can
be so effective if you do it right.
That brings us to the marketing plan.
How do we build a plan?
The way we look the marketing plans is quite
simple.
Awareness.
Trial.
Purchase.
And repeat.
It has to be generally in that order.
Why?
Because if I basically start jumping into
purchase, it's kind of like I met this pretty
girl at the Paul Oakenfold party tonight and
I say tomorrow morning, let's get married.
Uh, no, you're weird.
I am not going to call you again.
It's basically, you have to go through the
steps of the process so that you can convince
the consumer to get to the point where they
are going to consider a purchase.
You start with awareness.
Talk to them about what your product does.
Where they should get it.
Why it's unique.
How it's different.
There's a couple tools you can do here.
This is not exhaustive, of course.
Good PR.
One of the most underused things I see in
this industry.
Talk to the press, become their friends, make
sure that you send them their APKs, get them
to your studio to see what you are working
on.
It can be one of the most effective marketing
tools you can do and one of the cheapest is
to get these people to write about your apps.
I'll give you another tip.
Getting people to write about your apps has
a direct influence on your search rankings
in the play store.
It's called web anchoring.
It means that the more people kind of like
click on a link externally outside the play
store and come to your page, because they've
read about you, the better you will index
in the search rankings.
Social.
We talked about virality.
Have a blog.
Invite people to comment on it.
Post your APKs on it.
Create discussion.
Get people to talk about it.
Of course, other basic tools.
Search ads, mobile ads.
If you get to the point where you have the
available cash, well, TV or above-the-line
media.
Then we talk about trial.
What can we do for trial?
We talked about some of the business models
earlier today.
We can have a free trial version.
A version where I can use the app for 30 days.
And then it's great because I don't have to
pay pour it and I can really figure out if
I like it.
Why is trial so important?
Very simple, guys.
It's very important because essentially many
consumers out there have never experienced
content before.
Many consumers out there are getting a smartphone
for the first time and they will think this
content stuff is marvelous.
Are they going to shell four five bucks or
euros if they have never tried content before?
Probably not in some cases.
By providing a free version of your application,
you generate that comfort level.
When I was in the soft drinks business -- I
worked at Pepsi for many years.
When we would launch a new drink in the market,
we would go out and give hundreds of thousands
of cans to people.
We'd have these pretty girls in mini skirts
and walking down in the middle of traffic
and they would knock on your door, how about
a can of Pepsi max?
Why did we do that?
Trial.
We want to make sure that the consumers love
the product.
Hopefully they like the girls, too.
But they love the product.
So that when they go to the supermarket, they
have had it, tried it.
Yeah, yeah, this is pretty good stuff.
I think I'll buy a six-pack.
Same thing goes for apps and games.
We move on to purchase.
Purchase, of course, there are other things
we can do.
We can do direct response campaigns where
we are pushing people to download the app.
They have heard about it.
They have read about it on Tech Crunch.
They have read the blogs.
Talked to their friends about it.
We can do notifications.
We are saying, hey, guess what, you have now
been playing my game for 30 days, it's time
to pay up.
They may or may not do that.
But, of course, at least they have had the
opportunity to try it because you have gone
through step two.
Lastly, repeat.
Third rule of marketing.
Always easier to get money from an existing
consumer than a new consumer.
Makes sense but a lot of people don't follow
that rule?
How do we keep the consumer interested.
We heard about it in monetization panel.
Right?
You give them more don't.
You upgrade your app frequently.
You introduce new features.
You give them new reasons to pay for this
stuff.
You provide updates.
You have CRM campaigns because you've actually
been talking to your consumers for the past
three years and you have an email database
of 150,000 loyal fans who have downloaded
your app.
That's all about repeat.
But we do have a pretty good idea already
of what kind of stuff works.
So when I was talking about research earlier
in the session, we did this over the last
couple of weeks.
We put out a couple of questions on google.com/insights,
paid about a thousand bucks, whatever, basically
asked people, what influences your decision
to install an app?
U.S. only consumers, granted.
We got about 1500 responses which is statistically
significant.
And here's what they told us.
I'm influenced by user reviews.
Top apps lists.
User ratings.
And screen shots.
Those are the top four.
Now, obviously, it doesn't mean that they
are not influenced by the rest.
But they are influenced by a lot of stuff
that you guys control.
You control the user ratings because you can
control how good your product is and how frequently
you update it.
And how many cool features you build in and
how many crap features you take out.
You control the text description.
Because you read the great marketing slides
that talk about how important creative is
and you built killer text, great assets and
super powerful video that have gone totally
viral on YouTube.
So you control a lot of that stuff.
And search, you don't control that directly
but you do control it indirectly.
Why?
Tip number two: The other thing that affects
your search rankings in the Google Play store,
is the number of installs.
The more installs you have, the higher you
are on the search rankings.
However, caveat, the more uninstalls you have,
the lower your search rankings, which is why
you have to be careful when you use marketing.
Because if your product is not good enough
and you get a lot of installs and then more
uninstalls than installs because people figure
out your app was not good, it is going to
penalize your search rankings.
The last one on the list is paid advertising
or search.
Paid search, AdMob ads.
That stuff can be very effective at scale
but isn't necessarily the primary things that
drives interest from consumers.
Wow.
Lots of stuff.
It's time to advertise.
It's time to get out there and spend my hard-earned
dollars advertising to consumers.
What do I do?
Well, we typically break this down into two
different components, if you will.
One component is, of course, brand awareness
or brand advertising.
Many consumers are very familiar with this,
typically bigger brands do this.
But also developers who aspire to really build
a long-lasting presence on mobile are starting
to do this.
And the thing that we're starting to see after
three or four years now on the smartphone
app space, you are starting to see the emergence
of the world's first mobile brands, which
is really cool.
Right?
These are apps that have basically built their
reputation and built their brand on mobile.
Angry Birds, massive brand started on mobile.
Lookout Mobile Security, security app, started
on mobile.
Uber, some of you guys, little more niche,
started on mobile.
We're seeing more and more mobile brands and
brands being built for the first time through
mobile.
When we tuck about brand advertising, that's
stuff like if I come up with a cool video
for my app and I promote that through YouTube.
I might not necessarily get a ton of people
to buy it but I create a lot of awareness.
Why?
Because a picture is worth a thousand words
and a video is worth a thousand pictures.
That's brand awareness.
That's brand advertising.
TV, outdoor, YouTube, videos, that's brand
awareness.
How do you measure that stuff?
You might ask, why on earth would I do this?
I need to be able to measure this.
If I do an AdMob campaign, I can measure the
clicks.
That's true, but you can measure brand.
It's a different way of doing it.
Essentially what you need to do is you run
what's called a brand tracker which can be
very simple exercise of asking three to four
questions to your base of consumers every
single month.
And you ask them questions like, for example,
among the following kinds of sports apps,
which have you heard of?
You list all the apps, yours and your competitors.
That's aided brand awareness.
You can ask another question which is, which
sports apps have you heard of in general?
That's unaided brand awareness.
You can ask questions, for example, of in
the next four weeks, do you intend to purchase
a sports app?
That's purchase intent.
So there are a lot of ways to measure brand
awareness.
Most of your time, however, is probably going
to be focused on the second bullet which is
all about direct response.
And in that case what you're looking at is
stuff like search, mobile ads, incentivized.
So tip number four: Search at least for us
when we are promoting the Google Play store
has been one of the most effective ways to
actually advertise.
Why?
First of all, because the click through rate,
which our colleagues previously mentioned,
is higher on search generally than any other
medium.
Why is that?
Because search is an active advertising form.
Search basically provides a request, provides
information to a consumer who is already looking
for something specific.
Therefore, the odds are that that person is
more interested in that result because it's
specific to what they are looking for.
If I do a search on sports apps and I see
your app and I'm interested in sports, the
probability is higher that I'm going to download
that.
That's going to be more cost effective for
you and higher probability that that person
is actually going to install your application.
Typically, what would you expect from a good
mobile search campaign?
For us, we see good search result -- a good
click through rate on mobile search through
3, 4, 5% click through rate, or at least 2%,
somewhere around there.
Ads you can use and are a great way to scale
your marketing efforts but are typically going
to be a little bit less effective?
Why?
Because ads essentially are a passive means
of advertising.
The consumers playing a game on a web site
somewhere and they see an ad and basically
it's a passive experience.
I'm either interested in or I'm not.
But I'm not specifically making a proactive
search for it, so I'm probably not looking
for your application.
Web site typically a good response rate for
Mobile ad campaign can be .5, .6, .7, .8%
CTR, vastly different from what you would
get on search.
Perhaps more targeted in certain cases and
perhaps we can get more scale but, again,
different results.
So here we're going to actually run another
video where we interviewed another one of
our top developers, this case it was Pocket
Gems telling us about their experience marketing
and what worked for them.
[ Video ]
>>> Hi, I'm Arjun Dayal, Android product leader
for Pocket Gems.
>>> And Michael Dawson, I lead business development
in Pocket Gems.
>>> Pocket Gems is a Mobile gaming focused
company that was founded in 2009 and is backed
by Sequoia Capital.
Our titles have been downloaded 60,000 times
and on Android specifically we've had five
titles released in the past nine months.
Marketing in Pocket Gems allows us to inform
our community about our new unique experiences.
What we found is that by focusing on creating
unique experiences applied to the broadest
audience what we're able to do is get the
most engagement out of our user base.
>>> For us the goal is to get our games in
front of as many people as possible.
Google Play has been the most important for
that with by far the largest audience.
>>> For marketing messages a lot of the data
is really centered around engagement.
And for that -- we're able to engage the effectiveness
of messages and how connected our community
and population is based on the amount of time
they spent in the app and the number of times
they looked at different aspects.
>>> We take a multichannel approach.
The most important channel is cross-promotion
for us but we layer on to that and PR, paid
advertising channels, as well as work to start
word-of-mouth campaigns.
We love talking to game writers and tech writers
as well as Android-specific bloggers.
>>> We have a lot of fun with the creative.
We take our iconic characters, we put them
in simple backgrounds and then create a bunch
of versions of those and then we AB test that
creative.
So as an example with Top Dragon Park, we
took our little baby dragon Nixon and we tried
him in different colors and found people loved
blue the best so we made blue the icon in
a lot of our ad-creating.
>>> So in Tap Zoo and Tap Dragon Park over
the last couple months, we've had a number
of different special promotions and specialized
requests that have allowed our users to get
creative.
>>> We look to get the word out about our
games right before they launch, so this can
either be pure mouth of friends telling friends
or it can be in the games telling people about
new games we've launched.
>>> When we're about to launch an app, we
create a number of different assets, including
app icons, feature graphics, future graphics,
promotional graphics, viral videos and descriptive
screen shots that allow users who have not
download the game yet to understand what it's
like to actually play the game.
[ Video concludes ]
>>Patrick Mork: Cool, that's about advertising.
The last thing I really wanted to talk about,
the last P of the four Ps, is, of course,
distribution.
So you guys may remember I said at the beginning
of the presentation that I was a Pepsi guy,
that I had blue blood that flows throughout
my veins.
And I was one of these freaks that would not
drink a vodka Coke because it had Coke in
it so I'd just drink the vodka.
So it does pain me to say this but why is
Coke still it?
Why does Coke still beat Pepsi?
Distribution.
It's not necessarily they have a stronger
brand.
It's certainly not that they have better advertising.
Coke today is available in more countries
of the world freely and accessibly than bottled
drinkable water.
That sounds like a joke.
It is very true.
The thing that built Coke distribution muscle,
and some of these pictures prove it.
You can find Coke anywhere.
I have found Coke the most outrageous places
possible and, of course, it pissed me off
because I wanted Pepsi.
The same kind of thing needs to influence
your decision when you think about distribution.
Your distribution does not end when you go
live on the play store.
Maybe it does on iOS but not on the play store.
Our goal is virality and virality means reach.
So how do we tackle distribution, is that
developers, all the first stuff, of course,
is device coverage, we look at all those devices,
we look at the market, we anticipate the new
devices coming out on the market, and we think
to ourselves, what devices do I need to be
on, what are the legacy devices that still
have a lot of attraction, what are the new
devices that are still hot that I need my
game to be on?
The more devices that we're on, the more people
are going to talk about our great products
and it's going to go viral and I'm not going
to have to worry if the user has the phone
or not because I have the app for it.
The second step is channel coverage.
Of course we're thrilled you guys use Google
Play and we think Google Play is going to
be your main distribution channel for a long
time to come.
But that doesn't mean it's the only distribution
channel.
And the fifth tip of the day is distribute
your application on as many distribution channels
as makes commercial sense for you.
Wherever that might be.
If you go, for example, to WIP connector.org
which is a site run by the wireless industry
partnership which is a nonprofit geared toward
helping developers there's a whole section
on that site that talks about app stores and
app distribution channels cross all the OSs,
not just Android.
So in that respect, do yourselves a favor
and distribute on as many channels as makes
sense for you.
Whether that's carrier portals or carrier
freeloads or third-party app stores, if it
makes sense and you can reach more people
and you can get more viral, go for it.
The third step, of course, is in line with
our thinking about virality and that's OS
coverage.
And consumers have a great experience on an
Android app, but if they have a lot of friends
who, God forbid, have iPhones, well, why should
those people not be able to get your app as
well.
It all helps you go viral, right?
So have your app available, again, on as many
OSs as is commercially viable, as makes business
sense for you because it's going to drive
your virality.
When we look back at the case of e-buddy,
these guys were available on every single
platform known to man, including, for example,
Mobile web.
And lastly, of course, analyze, optimize,
prioritize constantly.
Look at your distribution channels, look at
your downloads by installed devices, look
at your downloads by channel and then reprioritize
every quarter, look at the data, analyze.
Rinse, repeat, and start over.
Lastly, of course, you're always going to
need a little bit of luck.
Cross your toes, cross your fingers, hope
it all works.
So we've been through a lot of stuff today.
People are probably tired.
People are probably thirsty.
We have a really cool fireside chat coming
up which I hope you guys will stay for.
The other thing I wanted to point out is there's
going to be a great session on day three,
11:30 a.m, about measurement, it's going to
go into a lot of detail, helping you guys
analyze how your performance of your campaigns
are going.
Today we've covered a lot of stuff.
We've talked about our product.
We've talked about our business models.
We've talked about our promotions and how
we advertise and promote our apps, the kind
of assets we've built.
We've talked about distribution.
All the different ways that we can go viral.
And, of course, we have our great checklist.
So we really have a lot of stuff for you guys
to sink your teeth into.
But before we go, a little gift for you guys,
it's a detail on the grand scheme of things
that you're getting.
So we really want you guys to build great
stuff.
We really want you to play and work hard and
when you work hard we want you to play even
harder.
So we have a couple of tee shirts.
These tee shirts are pretty special to us.
Simple reason.
These tee shirts were created, there were
only a couple hundred created, and they were
only created for members of the Google Play
team when we launched Google Play as a brand.
That's part of the big celebration we did
three months ago.
These are pretty much the last five that are
left that have not been given out to consumers.
So I'm going to ask you a couple of questions
to see how much of this stuff you absorbed.
See how fired up we are about marketing.
Are we going to do research and know our users?
>>> Yes.
>>PATRICK MORK: What?
>>PATRICK MORK: All right.
Are we going to develop some really magical
kick-ass Android apps?
>>> Yes.
>>PATRICK MORK: What?
>>PATRICK MORK: All right, that's better.
And lastly, are we going to build som awesome
bad-ass marketing plans to connect those users
with our magical properties?
>>> Yes.
>>Patrick Mork: What?
>>Patrick Mork: All right.
Thank you very much.
Have a great time at I/O.